est-ce que je pose une question pardon
mais Mathieu va arriver dans quelques
instants alors allons-y on va commencer
à préparer l'arrivée majorité forcée
Mathieu devait la poser quelqu'un c'est
déjà fini un truc dans le Hulk en fait
non
non non
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous expliquer une histoire
véridique que ma mère m'a dit que ça va
passionner tout le monde vas-y un matin
ma mère pourrait me lève elle me change
et tout et là tout d'un coup elle voit
que j'ai autour de l'anus plein de
petits points de couleur un truc de
fille des confettis là les crayons de
couleur juste à côté les feutres juste à
côté elle va avoir le pied mais votre
enfin mon enfant voilà je me surveillé
ce matin et tout il avait plein et je
dis bah écoutez il est en train de se
découvrir sa zone anale elle a dit en
tout cas il est intelligent parce qu'il
a pris précaution de retirer et les
bouchons
[Applaudissements]
j'avais une sœur infirmière urgence
et qui me disait les gens qui arrivent
avec des trucs improbables notamment une
boule de pétanque non elle me dit le
moment le cochonnet quand il vient
t'expliquer que la boule de pétanque
elle s'est retrouvée là totalement par
hasard donc voilà et ça aussi ça reste
dans les annales